uh where have you guys been what you
guys been doing in the meantime you guys
been traveling around
you've been doing anything interesting
well before lockdown before lockdown
from when we could travel
in the little bits that we could um we
recently just went camping
all right i know i couldn't come i know
the plans i
did really fine events and i was like
yeah i wanted to come camping with you
yeah so
me and like four of our friends went
camping in the mountains of shizuoka
yeah
it was my first experience camping in
japan and uh
definitely was a very different
experience if you've never been camping
before
i recommend you go camping in japan
because it is like
mario kart baby mode camping yeah it
really is
you roughly describe it to me but you're
saying there's like electricity okay
okay so
so so let me tell you about this right
so
um i've only been camping i think once
or twice else in my life
okay so wait okay with one question did
you get like a lot
what's that like a square yeah yeah yeah
yeah so we had to we had to book it yeah
we had to book a lot
so my only other experience camping has
been just like in the middle of the
[ __ ] fields like i
i went on like a trip in colorado where
we just like rode horses for eight hours
and we camped literally in the middle of
like the woods in colorado
that was like that was what i thought it
was gonna be [ __ ] fantastic it was
[ __ ] great
i thought it was gonna be something
similar yeah so uh so
i'm not that experienced camping so i
was i asked i asked the boys so what
should i be bringing right and they they
give me the usual or sleeping bags
um you know tents um warm clothes and
everything and also like a power bank to
charge your phone
so i came in with the expectations of i
need to buy
a big [ __ ] power bank because we're
not gonna have any power there yeah yeah
like two days yeah yeah yeah so a friend
edo he has this thing called like the
omni charge i can't remember the full
name
but that it was it looked like a [ __ ]
battle station i remember
yeah yeah but like it was way bigger
than any of the portable chargers i've
ever seen
and also like what sold me was that it
had its own plug so you can plug like
so you can you can use the adapter yes
you can plug an actual like
power adapter to it right so i was like
i want something like that for a camping
trip yeah
right so i said oh what's this thing
called so
he calls he says it's the omnicharger so
i google it on amazon and unfortunately
they're not selling on amazon anymore
so i go to like the first link that's
recommended
for like that search and here's the
thing about amazon
is that you see a charger right
there's nothing to like quantify how
how big this charger is right just from
the image yeah yeah yeah
there's not many dimensions but i mean
you might not look at them yeah
sometimes it's like
buried in a wall of like text yeah yeah
it's buried in the wall of text so i
just see this
block right and i'm just like it's
probably around the same i mean it's
recommended from me searching the omni
charger yeah so he's probably about the
same
size right he's probably around the same
size
like thinking back like being like an
electronic an electrical ex electronic
and electrical engineer
we've got a masters i should have seen
like the amount of like charge it holds
but i didn't look about the amount of
charge it holds i just i just i was just
like
on like um [ __ ] autopilot mode i'm
just like yeah that looks good
buy that okay so wait a few days from
all my camping equipment that i bought
um and this [ __ ] massive package like
um
i wish you brought it with you today i
wish i did i wish she did this master's
pack this massive package gets delivered
to my door
i'm and i'm all right uh everything's
like boxed up so i don't know what
everything is
so the first thing i pick up it's
[ __ ] heavy it's this [ __ ] brick
and my first thought was
oh no have i bought like a sleeping bag
that's just like 10 times heavier than i
needed it
right and so i start unboxing it and i
see
this [ __ ] brick just in my hands
right
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] is this
what i've
i don't remember buying anything this
heavy yeah turn it around
and it's the [ __ ] charger and i'm
like no wait this must be how big is it
this must be a mistake um so joey joey
has a photo
it's on screen right now the photo of
this brick that i got i turn it around
i look at like the appliances that i can
power and it's just like okay so this
can power
phones it can you know charge tablets
and then it says you can charge laptops
it can power a [ __ ] mini fridge
and i'm just like you can power a mini
fridge a microwave and i'm just like
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] have i bought
this this thing he bought it literally
is like oh i found it
yeah so this is like a [ __ ] brick
that i bought
two routers strapped together yeah yeah
and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] mac mini i don't know what
i'm gonna be able to do with this cause
like
i can't take that on a plane because
like if i take it on a plane the tsa
probably thinks i'm going to bomb the
[ __ ] plane
you're gonna get [ __ ] arrested like
i'm probably gonna be on the [ __ ]
isis list if i take us from a plane
jesus christ so i can't even so i'm just
thinking to myself all right
i've made guys i've made a mistake
but it's okay because at least i can use
it on this camping trip
so like i lug this massive [ __ ] brick
in my
suitcase or in my bag sorry which is
probably like
like by itself the heaviest single
object in my bag for a camping trip yeah
um and so we get to this campsite and
you know we get we get a lot and we
start unpacking everything
and i see this metal box right i see
these metal box and i was just like
what the [ __ ] is that metal box my first
thought was oh it's probably like a safe
they provided right because
you know i hear about some american
campsites something like bear safes or
something so
i was thinking i might be a safe or
something um
and so i was like navi what's that and
he's just like just wait on let me show
you
he opens it up and it's the [ __ ]
power outlet
[Laughter]
like there's two power outlets i'm just
like
yes camping with my power up yeah right
and i'm just like
so wait there's literally no [ __ ]
reason for me to buy this [ __ ] brick
and lug this around
i can't take it anywhere can't take it
on a plane and apparently it's useful
and it's apparently it's useless for a
camping trip what the [ __ ] do i need
this for you literally i
i looked at that thing and i'm like
that's what people use for like
emergencies
like when like your house is flooded and
you have no electricity and like this is
the thing yeah
i'm out of your house for like a month
i'm just like if japan syncs ever
happens
i'm [ __ ] sorted man you are like the
top of the hierarchy like people have
been
fighting mud light lights no because i
remember the first night he like charged
his phone
well he was like i might as well use
this [ __ ] thing yeah so he charged
his phone right it was like 100
next morning phone is fully charged 97
he's three percent of his charge his
power his phone i'm like
this thing could last you like literally
like two months yeah i literally saying
i literally bought it just so i could
recharge my phone during during the
duration
like ventilation like yeah yeah yeah
yeah i
knew he was like [ __ ] way too
overkill when i opened it up it had a
vent that had like a fan
he turned it on and literally started
going
so funny